[Music]
so today I'm here to disappoint you by
talking about structure and and why in
many situations our data are useless
unless we've imposed some structure onto
them and basically how to go and spot
the sorts of problems where we need to
have this structural type of thinking
does that one here work for Amazon or a
publisher former publishers I'm gonna
give you a problem that sounds maybe a
little bit familiar you sell lots of
products and some of these products are
in competition with one another
so perhaps you sold chips or wine or
beer or or I don't know books and you're
selling many of these products and
they're in competition with one another
so the question is how do I go and get a
paradise at a price based on my analysis
that is going to optimize the profits
might for my entire portfolio of
products so maybe we are going to you
know go and listen to a demand we're
gonna run some randomized control trial
we're going to exhaustion ously berry
some prices of some books and not others
and then see what happens and from that
we're going to go and get estimates on
price elasticity and from that we're
going to work out what is a revenue
optimising price that's beautiful
so what how does that kind of reveal
itself well we've gone and we've
randomly changed some prices and we get
a curve that looks like this a revenue
curve if the price is zero then nobody
buys your products if the price is very
very high
not many people buy your products but
you're getting a lot of money for each
time you sell a product so somewhere in
between zero getting a lot of sales but
making no money on any of them and up
here make not many sales and making
quite a bit on each of them there is
going to be some revenue optimising
price if you know your cost structure as
well you can bake that in and get a
profit maximizing price but is it profit
max maximizing interesting thing with
these sorts of portfolios is that we can
perhaps go and decrease the price this
current price of this book here this red
line is clearly to the right of the
revenue optimising price
how about we decrease the price of this
in this case a book and see what happens
now when you're in the world of selling
many competing products you change the
price of one of them and there is an
equilibrium effect on your customers
your customers are going to substitute
away from some books that are similar
towards other books that are similar
similar if you you know this discount
dostoyevsky maybe the customers who
would have other bought otherwise bought
pushkin are gonna start buying
dostoyevsky okay so let's go and see
what the impacts of this is in this
particular model so we're on book 1 at
the moment
let's discount the price to 2 bucks
which is around the revenue optimising
price fantastic now what's happened
we're getting more sales from this
product and the LCD is such as that
we're increasing revenue for that
product where revenues shot up here our
revenue market share or shot up the unit
sales market share is shot up but what
has happened well there are other
products that I sell that have actually
been cannibalized okay so some of the
share has come from the other products I
sell and in some cases that share is
that decreasing share is really really
big now those are the products that are
similar so again think of this as being
I've you know discounted crime and
punishment and suddenly people who are
otherwise going to buy war and peace are
now buying crime and punishment so what
happens well the effect on the portfolio
isn't clear although we've maximized
revenues for this particular product
we've actually damaged our portfolio
sales our portfolio revenues have
decreased because we haven't taken into
account if we were just optimized this
price we haven't taken to a into account
the substitutions that really occur now
so this is kind of like leading with the
punchline of my talk and the punchline
of talk is there are many many
situations in which the data that we
observe
emerge from some some competitive or
preference based structure and what we
observe is in equilibrium and you can
throw the biggest neural net in the
world with a trillion data points and be
precisely wrong about inference away
from equilibrium so we're going to talk
today about the sorts of problems how to
spot these problems and a couple of
other things so let's jump into it now
before I get into that though we'll talk
about what is our toolkit what our data
scientist good at and what's where does
value get created because I think that
we should really be trying to maximize
the amount of value that we create how
do we productize these this sort of
framework and how does decision theory
and structural modeling fit into all
this
so as everyone here workers and
management consultants all work with
management consultants management
consultants love quadrants and one of
the quadrants they love is this one here
if you're trying to I mean what is
expected impact well its impact multiply
through by probability of success and
impact you're going to come up with some
idea of how to quantify that and
probability of success you need to go
and quantify that but it is a product
this is an expected value so we multiply
some function by its probability density
now this quadrant here I'm sorry about
the resolution on the x-axis it's
additional impact of success keyword is
additional we don't want to rewrite
msword we want to do things that haven't
been that done yet you could have a lot
of quote unquote impact by rewriting ms
word entirely but your additional impact
is zero no one's going to pay you for
you want to do something new same time
you've got probability of success now
you can think about the tasks that you
do on a daily basis as falling somewhere
on this in this quadrant in these
quadrants
you don't want to be working in the
bottom left-hand quadrant these are
things that you're not going to pull off
and even if you did they're useless
okay I've spent a lot of time down there
I think last night I was plotting war
deaths having an interactive plot of war
death three times it's you know up here
up here we've got tasks that you're
likely to be able to do easily and are
gonna have a huge impact if you do them
this is where you should be focusing
your time the question is what do i what
do our tools actually allow us to do
that it both impactful that we have a
pretty high confidence of success now
this is where you're gonna hate me
not yet you can hate me in a second
let's firstly talk about the x-axis
which is the sorry so the y-axis
probability of success what things are
we good at now I would say the thing
that we're probably best at is or at
least in theory is when we've got to cut
some outcomes that might be you know
outcome could be a winning winning a
game of go or chess or something or
classifying a picture we've got a set of
inputs or a state the state could be the
position of the pieces on the board or
the pixels in an image and where the
probabilistic outcome of the the outcome
is entirely defined by the initial state
okay so with go everything is all the
information and system is on the board
the feelings of the analysts have no
relevance at all what's happening
outside the weather no impact at all on
what's happening in a game of go it
turns out that for such systems we now
have technology that is growing at a
rate that essentially any problem of
this sort it's only a matter of time and
processing power and weather yarn I
can't work what's his name
no like Kuhn works on it okay so those
guys going working I put enough
processing power then then it's done at
the other end you've got going down
we've got things that we're pretty good
at which is
got robust signal and we're just bang
straight predictions okay we're not
making any predictions about
counterfactuals
we're just making plain expected value
predictions where there is a robust
signal data scientists are pretty good
at this going down further is we're in
the good good side of this we're really
good the bad side of it we're awful but
it's causal inference hopefully with
experimental data sometimes with
observational data here I'm trying to
start to think about counterfactuals I
want I want to know what happens when I
you know when atom flashes some changes
the title of some some BuzzFeed article
whether I'm gonna click on it he can go
and randomly vary that and sometimes I
am more likely to click and other times
I'm less likely to click but because
it's fairly controlled system and Adams
a really great course learning French
guy this is a pretty solved problem
going down way the other end you've got
like a lot of psychology observational
economics all this sort of stuff where
no you know think about macroeconomics
unfortunately we can't go and
exogenously very the monetary paul see
no rules we can't go and change the
interest rate really nearly just to see
what happens maybe we should but I'm not
sure we can now where we get really
really bad is incorporating uncertainty
into the decision-making this is very
very very important and yet we seem to
be very focused on first moments and not
so much on higher moments we should be
taking those uncertainty both in our
model and then our predictions into
account when we make decisions and what
we're really hopeless at is what my talk
is about is when we've got a system with
many agents who have the the following
structure when you've got multiple
people and they all differ and they all
have their preferences and they all have
their constraints and they're all
optimizing given their constraints in
such a way that we observe some some
come so this is where we really really
suck
whenever we want to do any
counterfactual analysis of this you need
to build a model and data scientists or
most of them unless they've come from
one or two little sub disciplines
hopelessly ill-equipped to do this it
doesn't stop them from trying but most
of analysis will be pretty bad okay so
that's what we're good at any
disagreements very good what adds value
now I like to think about the sorts of
things that add value as being whether
they impact a growth rate or whether
they impact a have a step change sort of
thing technologies that have a step
change sort of character to them these
are ones like a word processor you build
a word processor yes look I understand
word gets better every year that's
family marketing the step change is not
using a typewriter anymore it's being
able to do formatting and stuff in a
WYSIWYG environment it's a huge step
change but once it's built it's kind of
a step change another example might be
chatbots you know we're not very good at
check box yet but once they get good
we're just gonna you know get rid of
call center operators we're gonna have
chat BOTS and that's gonna be a step
change and some people going to get
extremely rich with these chat BOTS and
then we're gonna be there will just be
the new norm now I'm not saying that
these sorts of step change technologies
have a bad and and you shouldn't be
working on them but over time the sorts
of things that make at least some
countries rich in some countries poor
and and some businesses phenomenally
wealthy and others less wealthy is
changes to the rate of growth and that
rate of growth might be things like the
ability to execute on these step changes
but I'm thinking like being able to hire
excellent people being able to think
about what your opponents are going to
do and preamp them and have you know
strategic decision-making these things
affect the growth rate of value creation
and that's why CEOs and c-suite
executives get paid millions millions of
that's why
entrepreneurs make such a huge amount of
money because they can create value by
changing the growth rate so I don't know
what's what we should be prefer I know
we're probably better at this one but I
think if you to observe a country or a
company for a very very long period of
time all the differences are in this
it's not in this so let's maybe
prioritize some data science effort down
in the bottom left hand corner we've got
10-day weather forecasts it's basically
impossible it's a chaotic system don't
bother
even if you could do it well huh it's
ten days like we've all read pretty good
two three day forecasts who's making ten
day weather decision like decisions
based on weather forecasts it doesn't
matter
don't bother on don't don't do this up
there
automated art we're pretty good at this
we can get you know you know various
neural nets to produce paintings
whatever it's completely useless
why bother at the top things I'm really
confident that we're gonna get pretty
soon based on like trajectory and the
fact that these are problems that are
defined by the inputs we've got
autonomous driving by computer vision or
x-ray class classification these sorts
of things they're closed systems they've
got pretty high quality information
these are solvable problems they're
maybe not easy problems but they're
solvable bottom right-hand corner or web
B let's talk about Clippy first and I'm
thinking about things like a lexer you
may have noticed that you can't
understand any word that I say because
I'm from a country on the other side of
the world call Australia and Alexa can
also not understand a word that I say
this was house you know crashing at a
friend's place the other day I had a I
had a talk in the morning I had to get
we're up at 4:30 to write the talk in
the morning and Alexa turn lights on
I cannot understand you it was actually
blaring out a pair of like bookshelf
speakers so they really hated being
working out by a lecture at 4:30 the
morning so nextgen cliffie a lecture and
the like might be a really great
technology maybe it's really good
maybe it's doable I don't know my
experience where these sort of
technology so far has been pretty
hopeless it's almost always easier to
turn on lights yourself or flip open
your iPhone and do stuff the things that
I'm really interested in either down
here now I don't think that we can do
equity price prediction we can maybe do
pretty good prediction in the second
moments so volatility of stocks but you
know doing first moment predictions of
equity prices is at least in the short
run is is pretty hopeless maybe in the
very very short run kind of the
high-frequency trading people might have
some good signal in the very long run
maybe in the short runs it's hopeless
using uncertainty in decisions the great
thing about using uncertainty and
decisions is we've already worked out
how to do it there have been people
working on this since the 40s or even oh
yeah but really formalized a lot of this
sort of thinking in the 40s and there is
already a huge theory about how to do
this now we have the tools to properly
quantify the posterior distributions for
our unknowns in in fairly large and
complex models this is something that is
now possible and Eric over here runs a
company that is doing exactly this did
you go and talk to Eric things like
automated HR I think this is one of the
really big games in sorry big payoff
games in in dart data science because
you can potentially add a huge amount of
value by improving HR processes this is
how you get good people's how you have a
high-growth company and the problems are
are insurmountable it's mainly data
cleaning Network
exploring networks or looser stuff these
are things that we're actually quite
good at the thing that I am really
fascinated by is automatic corporate
strategy I'll give you a couple of
examples of what I mean by that later
but this could come down from this is
like using data tools to help conceive
of a new product what product should I
create and everyone knows the kind of
house of cards storia where people
realize people like who liked was it
political thrillers and Kevin Spacey no
no you're not gonna talk about Kevin
Spacey today but house of cards
apparently came about because you know
analysts worked out that people really
like political thrillers and Kevin
Spacey and it's like well let's put
Kevin Spacey in a political thriller but
there are probably more complex sort of
problems that we can solve with quote
unquote automatic corporate strategy
that's where we learn a lot from game
theory and use those game theory to help
guide how our models work so I trust
you're all Miyazaki fans has anyone seen
this video there's these guys who pitch
Miyazaki on like a an AI that generates
animation Miyazaki is probably the
greatest animator of all time I would
never wish to incorporate this
technology into my work at all I
strongly feel that this is an insult to
life itself so don't do this stuff okay
so the other thing is that location that
where these types of technologies sit in
this quadrant is not static it's a
function of the technologies that we
have as technologies grow and change
then maybe some things that were in face
will become feasible maybe a technology
grows the impact of a clippie a good
Clippy a good alexa grows maybe it
really really helps disabled people just
not ones with an Australian accent but
but maybe these things going to move
around so having some foresight about
how technology changes are likely to to
affect the position on this chart is
really gonna steer what's
things got to be working on okay so
let's go into two of them a little bit
more deeply the first is decision theory
the decision theory it turns out is
pretty simple
so then we'll talk a little bit about
structural modeling okay so decision
theory is basically you want to do
things that maximize the expected
utility of of a choice okay so you can
think of each person considering a
perhaps can't walk perhaps uncountable
set of choices and this might be a
uncountable set of choices might be a
continuous price for a product okay
we're going to condition on a whole
bunch of unknowns so if you're choosing
price and see what he would just be a
price that we're gonna choose selling
and good theta is a set of unknown that
might be the price elasticity or
something else
I'm bunch of unknowns in our model we've
got some data Y that we've observed in
the past maybe from an experiment maybe
from just observing historical sales
we've got a loss function L this loss
function L for any values of the
unknowns and for any choice it we can
assess that that'll guide that loss
function now we really should be a
little bit careful and document loss
loss function because this is a really
important part of the the step you need
to elicit what decision you're actually
making a great example of this is an old
colleague of mine Andrew Landgraf who
won the NCAA challenge on Kegel earlier
this year so how did Andrew win the
n-c-double-a challenge well he worked
out that the idea of this game is not to
just predict who's which teams are going
to win the idea of this game and that
would just be a loss function on your
position classification here your
precision quality so your classification
quality the idea of this game is to
to be the highest-ranked position on the
board when there are lots of people
following various strategies so
sometimes what that means is that there
might be a team that is 49% likely to
know the probability of them winning is
49% and the probability of the other
team is 51% but because everyone else is
modeling that l10 51% they're all
betting on that team and maybe what you
ought to be doing is betting on the
other team and that's going to in
expectation increase your rank highest
so eliciting this loss function is the
important thing in this task one of the
important things the second one is that
you actually need to be uncertain you
know yeah you need to have well
calibrated uncertainty about the
distribution of your unknowns given the
data that you've observed and that's
what data scientist earthly file out on
the most part mostly we have point
predictions we're using optimization
techniques to back out what the most you
know likely candidates for feeder ah
and we have no uncertainty about those
and we're just going to not be able to
assess this posterior at all because we
don't know it the beautiful thing is
that then our choice if if we have all
these things our choice is simply the
argument of this very simple integral so
it's a weighted average of the loss
function over the joint distribution of
young known that's all this integral is
and we can assess what this integral is
for all possible seeds we just choose to
see that maximizes that which is
actually quite simple computers will do
this for us in seconds so the problem
with as I mentioned before is that most
data science techniques you know all
your machine learning techniques all
your neural nets all yeah as soon as
you're not using Bayes you're not
getting any distribution of your
unknowns you're getting point estimates
at best
sometimes they're awful point estimates
especially in high dimensional problems
decision Theory requires you're
uncertain that you're honest in your
uncertainty about the unknowns the model
so if you're getting point estimates you
just can't do this okay so let's go
through a little example we'll say we're
estimating a fairly rare event that
occurs with some probability specific to
the data theta so I the firm I work for
we lend money to alternative lenders in
sub-saharan Africa so microfinance banks
and and asset lenders cow lenders that
these sort of things now one of these
these sort of businesses they're all
gonna have some model of risk of all the
people in their portfolio and you might
think of let's say a cow cost $2000
they'll lend out a cow and you've got
some loan attached to that cow it's a
balloon payment at the end now you
observe how much milk that is coming
from that cow each fortnight maybe three
14 days and you try to infer the
probability that that person is is going
to default on the loan they're not going
to pay it back at the end now let's say
if that probability goes above 50% I'm
just going to take that receivable I'm
going to sell it off to a collections
agency for a thousand bucks and the
collections agent let the collections
agency deal with the we're trying to
extract more than a thousand dollars out
of out of the so I out of the customer
the end borrower so if probability is
greater than 0.5 I'm going to
quote-unquote spend 2,000 bucks off
loaned out 2,000 bucks letting me take
$1,000 hit otherwise I don't spend
anything so two ways of that we might do
this the first is that we build a
classifier to estimate you know we take
a random for something to work out what
the probability of person defaulting is
given how much milk we've seen the
second way of doing is we build a
Bayesian model now the question is under
these two approaches how does the loss
provisioning differ and lost
provisioning for those not in finance is
when you hold a bit of money aside or
you allocate and
since some money aside just to take just
in case that happens okay so so that you
don't overstate the size your book and
and loads of up on debt based on a book
that never really materializes so here
are three different densities for the
probability of the person defaulting the
first one that black line has an
expected value of 111th the second one
the red curve also has an expected value
of one xi and this dirac-delta this
spike is also on 111th so let's say
we've got three models they all give us
the same expected probability for this
person defaulting now this one here the
spike that's coming from say random
forest or something that I've just given
me a point estimate of business
probability the other two give me
distributions over the probability so
I'm uncertain about this probability so
what I can do is I know what that loss
function is is described my loss
function so if I work out the integrand
which is simply the loss function across
the probability density well here it is
so you can see the one that this black
curve here has a really fat tail and the
weight it gives above here we get a
multiplied by the sum of of this of the
cost which is you know a thousand bucks
if if the probability goes above 0.5 the
red curve gives far less weight to a
probability about 0.5 and so we give
much less weight much less negative
utility here or look much less loss here
and of course this spike here gives no
weight at all to probability greater
than 0.5 and so we're not going to
provision any losses at all so 3
probability probability estimates three
different losses that we're going to
provision on so the first one
probability is less than 0.5 so the
expected loss is zero totter posterior
expect the losses 10 cents
with the loose posterior is back this is
not a huge difference of course there
are situations where you know when
you're talking about extinction events
nuclear war these sorts of things where
we where we might want to actually take
some cost to to stop a negative
infinitive outcome
this whole Pascal's wager sort of thing
for the religious people in here this
neither these large negative values can
really can really matter
so that's decision theory in a nutshell
the second part of the talk is I'm gonna
say part of the talking we've got a few
minutes is that we have we want to build
structural models now so what is the
structural model we've got as I said
before we've got a whole bunch of
economic agents an agent could be a
person a firm a government whatever each
of those agents is trying to maximize
something okay they've got some
preferences they care about things and
they the things they care about are
likely very very high-dimensional you
know what are you what are you
maximizing well you're not just
maximizing money you probably you what
spend too much talent work you want
spend time with your family you want to
go on a couple holidays he aid you
really love Japanese food like you
you're trying to maximize a high
dimensional object okay now when you've
got a whole bunch of these actors then
you can have some notion of equilibrium
so you need to think what is the
mechanism by which these people or
actors firms governments whatever come
together and and you know they're not
bargaining or they might write contract
so they might have sales or whatever
that result in the data that I observe a
great example there's came across the
other day of a sort of problem that
could be answered with a structural
model and while we might well think
about this and in a non-economic setting
is a friend of mine who was asked to do
some analysis of
you know you got planes on the runway
and they're taxing about and this person
was asked could you do a ranking of
potential policies that could reduce the
probability of having accidents on the
runway having two plans crash into each
other okay difficult problem why is that
well how many planes have you ever heard
of crashing into each other in on the
runway how many affirmative cases do you
have how many plans take off every day
how many planes are on the runway every
day you have essentially zero
affirmative cases it is really difficult
to assess the change in probability of
an accident
when you have zero affirmative cases in
your data set so you gotta have to come
up with some structural model you gonna
have to come up with an idea of how
pilots and air traffic controls are
making decisions and see how changes to
the the you know the structure changes
to the rules trying to sort of lay out
at the airport are going to affect that
decision-making that's the only way you
can really do this in an analytical
setting okay so when you've got a whole
bunch of these actors and they're all
doing what's best for them well
something approximately good for them
what we get is some quote unquote
general equilibrium all observations are
made in equilibrium so that is you can't
just throw some neural net at
equilibrium outcomes of such a system
and it's expect it to perform or say
anything sensible at all if you were to
perturb one of the one of the input
since that in that system so if I want
to change prices or if I were to change
the rules or anything like that
I your models going to say something
stupid and one of the classic cases you
get with price elasticity modeling is
when you go in and estimate some big
predictive model on this and find out
that when you increase prices well sales
will increase as in the number of units
sold will increase that's a classic
finding because a lot of the things that
drive prices also drive sales
fashionability or advertising or
whatever
okay so if you are working with the
system where your observations are
coming from such an equilibrium where
there is some game or some market that
brings together people and your the data
that you have emerged from this
equilibrium and if you're not using
theory your models bunk and you need to
do something else so a fun example in
Australia is all these roots in the
desert so we've got these regional
centers and I spend a fair bit of time
in Darwin which is up in the north it's
near Indonesia kind of tropical town and
you go to the airport and Darwin there
are all these guys in like fluro jackets
and big boots like steel cap boots and
they've got big beers they look like the
sort of Australia's you want to see they
smell like like rum they're all flying
for these little towns and these towns
are in the desert they know or mining
towns mainly iron ore now the people
paying for their flights not them the
people paying for their flight to the
mining companies if you were to go and
try and work out what the optimal price
is for one of these these flights what
you might do is randomly vary the price
that's a great tool that we've got
exogenous variation of the price and
what you would find in a small limited
experiment is that you're going to sell
just many tickets because the mining
companies need to have you know boots on
the ground so well we're like hmm I
don't care what price I say well let's
profit maximizers let's Jack the price
up and yet what we have observed in
equilibrium
our prices that are not crazy when you
go and look at how much those flights
cost they're not crazily expensive it's
like what's going on are these airlines
leaving like million dollar bills on the
table that's what is that what's
happening of course not
the people who run these airlines are
not done what they realize is that it's
something called contestable market type
officers if you have a might have an
on route that can be competed by any if
it's open if there's no legal you know
monopoly that's being granted to the
existing incumbent anyone can fly that
route and if they were to jack up their
prices high enough they're inviting
competition as a consequence you have
never observed the counterfactual of
what would happen if you were to
increase the price permanently okay so
what we've got equilibrium observations
those equilibrium observations often
don't come from people you know running
the numbers they come from people who
understanding of theory and an industry
a second another example which comes
from my work whoops is in pricing loans
so one of the things that people do
especially with like bulky purchases if
they'll buy them on credit so it might
be they might buy a car or they might
buy some furniture or in the case of one
of my customers in sub-saharan Africa
they learn that motorbikes and these
motorbikes are paid back over some time
now how the scheme worked was on a
scheme sorry how the contract works is
that you pay some fixed proportion of
the face value if you were to pay cash
today but you get that same price for
the first I think it's about 10 months
is their contract if you were to pay it
off within 10 months then you get the
today cash price it's about you know 78%
I think of the of the full price that
you could possibly pay after 10 months
this is the red line up top after 10
months some interest starts kicking in
if you've ever bought one of those
furniture sort of deals where you get
the cash price on day one you know you
need to pay it back the day before your
interest starts kicking in otherwise
they'll charge you some large amount of
interest okay so I think interest kicks
in and you need to have paid off by the
end so when you observe the actual
payments of customers they look like
this these black lines up here there are
many black lines everyone's paying off
the minimum amount sometimes people have
an accident there's a motorcycle taxi
drivers so sometimes they have it crash
they give it a month leeway but they get
they start repaying and then you see a
whole bunch of people they get to month
ten and they make that last payment they
they pay it off because they don't want
to pay the interest as people cook you
on progressing more and more people have
enough liquidity to pay off the loan and
you get lots of people something like
half a portfolio engages in this sort of
behavior the other half just pay off the
minimum payment until the end those
people are paying about 20% more than
then the people who pay off for the
beginning so why am I telling you this
well what we can do is say that these
decisions are made optimally given
customers sorry the borrower's
behavioral parameters in this case
they're discount rate okay so just can't
write it's how much you don't care about
the future if you've got a high discount
rate you don't care about the future
people with a low discount rate do care
about the future so it's likely that
people who are paying off at the
beginning have a low discount rate it's
likely that people at the top have a
high discount rate we can actually back
out these structural parameters the
distribution of discount rates across
the population from spec by specifying a
model and then what we can actually use
is to help it desert use that model to
help us design new financial products
for instance what happens if I decrease
the cash price proportion what if I push
the month of discount out let's extend
it to a 22 month term let's say the
outside interest rate the rate they can
borrow from other banks increases the
unit price decreases so now I've got
some model I've changed multiple things
not just one thing multiple things and
it's a structural model so I can run
simulations and my computer is running
these a moment it'll be it's low then
eventually shining will update and I can
see what the impact on my internal rate
of return for the portfolio is going to
be there we are we've dropped out
internal rate of return about a percent
good month
so that is fundable example of a
structural model in practice finally
what sort of things should we be
considering when we put these into
products like what we excel at is
turning data science into product that's
our forte
unfortunately structural modeling
requires you have some domain knowledge
requires that you can understand a
problem quite deeply you can't just
throw a tool at it so this is a really
big concern what we're good at though is
productizing I think that you know I am
personally working towards these goals I
know Eric and Dan and working on those
goals Adams done a whole bunch of stuff
writing libraries to try and prioritize
a lot of this sort of stuff we also one
of the things that we have is this much
better knowledge than economists of how
to you know turn or what sort of
interesting nonlinear models we have
things like splines things like trees
throwing things like neural nets
whatever we can use a whole bunch of
techniques that are essentially curve
fitting and I think we can do a lot
better than a lot of economists who
aren't so familiar with these techniques
and so they're kind of assuming
linearity everywhere for a lot of the
structural parts of their models so we
can do better than that then and yet the
one thing that we really really need to
do to become good at this sort of thing
is to you know invest in getting that
outside knowledge that knowledge that
experts have you need to go out to lunch
with people you need to try to elicit
the the information from them in a smart
way so that's my talk my spiel on
structural models any questions we got
like a minute half
[Applause]
[Music]